[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
maurice val au bonjour je faisais mon
coup d'être avec nous porte parole du
parti socialiste on est ensemble pendant
20 minutes pour une interview au
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représentée par stéphane bern
est bonjour stéphane bonjour au regard
d'un qui dirige le bureau parisien du
journal ouest france
on commence boris vélo avec ces
nouvelles violences
hier cette fois c'est à champigny sur
marne marne dans le val de marne qui est
une nouvelle rixe un adolescent de 14
ans est actuellement entre la vie et la
mort un autre a été grièvement blessée
valérie pécresse la présidente de région
appelle à arrêter l'angélisme comme on
lutte contre cette violence qui devient
maintenant quasi quotidiennes d'abord
c'est terrible d'apprendre à nouveau que
des bandes rivales règlent leurs comptes
de quoi s'agit-il un coup de couteau des
gamins c'est absolument terrible
la réponse elle est évidemment policière
sécuritaire dans la proximité de la
police une police de proximité de
quartiers que que les gens connaissent
et sur lesquels ils peuvent compter est
aussi éducative c'est les moyens de
l'école c'est la mixité sociale dans des
établissements scolaires c'est les
services publics c'est les éducateurs
spécialisés
autant de moyens qui font souvent défaut
dans un certain nombre de nos de nos
quartiers de nos villes et de nos et de
nos villages s'agit pas de faire de
langeais me lisent
il s'agit d'apporter des réponses sur
tous les terrains parce que ce sont nos
enfants moi j'ai des enfants qui sont à
peine plus jeune que cela et c'est
absolument glaçant que d'imaginer que il
pourrait se retrouver au milieu d'une
rixe qui se termine comme ça c'est plus
de bagarre de cour d'école loyer ou de
cours de collège sont des choses bien
plus graves et il faut s'en saisir je ne
mesure pas si c'est un phénomène de
société il faudrait qu'on puisse avoir
de ce point de vue là des éléments
statistiques des éléments des plus
d'interroger semé forme de banalisation
de la violence c'est la question qu'il
faut qu'on se mette mais c'est le
résultat d'une faillite collective tous
gouvernements confondus
écoutez je ne sais pas si on peut en
tirer des conclusions définitives il
faut se garder de cela en tout cas c'est
extrêmement préoccupant il faut aussi
apporter des réponses fortes sur le
terrain de la police de proximité sur le
terrain de la réponse éducative
je pense notamment à la question des
éducateurs spécialisés
qu'ils font quand ils le peuvent un
travail extrêmement important ça a été
fait pour paris il ya plusieurs années
il ya eu plusieurs plans mis en place
par la préfecture par la ville il ya
plus de dix ans maintenant
pour juguler la montée des violences en
bandes j avec jets régionaux et avec des
résultats qui sont alors c'était
difficile qui sont positifs ces sources
est ce qu'on peut pas les dupliquer dans
l'est dans la zone ce qu'on a
l'impression que le phénomène simplement
se répand par capillarité très
probablement ile-de-france au qu'il faut
le faire qu'il faut s'inspirer de ce qui
a fonctionné pour le reproduire partout
en france mais c'est une réponse à la
fois jeudi de proximité de la de la
police et des réponses et des réponses
éducatives et puis ensuite il ya des
questions plus larges de politique de
l'habitat du logement de la mixité à
l'école
et puis cette banalisation des violences
elle est aussi éducatif dans le rapport
aux médias et aux réseaux sociaux dans
le rapport peut être un certain nombre
de 2,2 de jeux vidéo en tout cas voilà
travaillons sur ces sujets avec la
gravité que cela commande et avec la
détermination de sortir nos enfants de 7
ans droite jusque dans la surveillance
des messages de que les enfants
eux-mêmes échanges sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est d'abord le travail des
parents d'abord le travail des parents
et de ce point de vue là j'appelle les
parents effectivement à une vigilance
vis-à-vis de leurs enfants et de ce
qu'il ce qu'ils font de ce qu'ils disent
ce sont des jeunes des jeunes enfants
avec ce que cela veut dire que ça veut
dire que la responsabilité première des
durées 10 par an pour vous bien sûr
toujours toujours on va parler d'un
autre sujet maurice ballon on a beaucoup
de sujets d'actualité à voir ensemble la
crise sanitaire le gouvernement mise
donc sur l'accélération de la
vaccination jean castex est à nouveau ce
matin à 9 heures dans un centre de
vaccination est ce que vous approuvez
cette stratégie ou est ce que vous dites
au vu des chiffres c'est peut-être un
pari risqué
écoutez vous savez dès le 13 octobre je
posais une question d'actualité au
gouvernement sur le vaccin en suggérant
d'accélérer parce que je pressentais que
nous étions en retard
nous sommes en retard nous l'avons dit
nous sommes en retard dans une europe
qui elle même est à la peine par rapport
au royaume uni à israël aux états unis
et donc oui il faut d'accélérer mais il
faut accélérer avec constance et pas par
à-coups et quand je vois qu'il ya une
grosse campagne de vaccination ce
week-end mais que dans le même
temps on dit que cette semaine les
médecins généralistes ne pourront pas
commandé de doses je m'en mets toi parce
que les doses sont réservés aux
pharmaciens cette semaine ou de partir
du 15 mars et vacciné voyez ça fait
aussi un petit moment que nous suggérons
que les sas et de logistique est
justement de doses disponibles
comprendre voilà dix semaines que la
campagne de vaccination a été lancée il
ya 40 % des dossiers tels chiffres avant
le week-end on va voir ce qu'ils sont
aujourd'hui des doses disponibles qui
n'avait pas été injecté est-ce que cela
relève d'une stratégie ou est-ce que
cela relève d'une difficulté en termes
de de logistique
on a des licences aussi à des doses qui
était réservé aux soignants les
soignants les soignants avec ses
soignants à eux seuls ne sont pas ce qui
explique il faut que thaksin bien sûr je
crois que c'est important de donner
donné l'exemple montré que l'obliger
cette vaccination par me sens obligée il
faut pas infantiliser les uns et les
autres
je crois que il faut le faire qu'ils
vont le faire mais ce n'est pas
l'essentiel du retard il ya beaucoup de
gens et cela nous romont dans les
territoires qui pourtant sont éligibles
et ne parviennent pas à obtenir des
résultats il y a d'un département à
l'autre
des doses disponibles qui ne sont pas
les mêmes en proportion de la population
il ya des jets dire des vaccinations
plus intensive dans certains territoires
que dans notre pourquoi ces retards
pourquoi ces différences dont il a
besoin
ces vaccinations plus intensives sont
elles sont liées à la progression de la
maladie ou pas non si on a regardé ça
nous avons écrit au premier ministre par
la voix de valérie rabault la semaine
dernière pour l'interroger
on s'est posé la question et larribe le
nombre de doses il ya un pensionnat
perret qui a pas d'explication en tout
cas que dans le bas lecture les nerfs
qui a pas la campagne les campagnes de
vaccination ne sont pas concentrés dans
les départements où a priori on en
aurait plus besoin c'est ça vous êtes en
train ou bien que d'un département à
l'autre
il y a des différences xmb un nombre de
personnes vaccinées qui ne s'explique
pas par soit l'incidence de la maladie
soit la part des plus de 75 ans par
exemple si on devait prendre ses deux
deux éléments allait demander des
explications près ministre autrement par
cette lettre
bien sûr je crois qu'il doit y avoir à
nouveau d'un débat à l'assemblée
nationale et au sénat le 24 25 ce soit
seulement une discussion badine pour
nous expliquer qu'on est les meilleurs
du monde ce comme c'est souvent mais
pourquoi nous en sommes là rappelez-vous
les chiffres qui avait été annoncé au 20
mars nous rions être à 14 millions de
vaccinations c'était ce qui était
annoncé en
et ce en août et c'est dans une semaine
vous voyez bien que nous n'y serons pas
puisque nous avons fait je crois à 6
millions d'injections quelle quelle est
votre position sur le concernant le pass
sanitaire évoqué par le gouvernement
c'est un moment de questionnement je
veux dire qu'il ya d'abord il faut
savoir ce qu'on entend par passe
sanitaire est ce qu'il s'agit pour la
circulation internationale
à la question peut se poser dans la
mesure où beaucoup de nos partenaires
le mettre en place est ce qu'il s'agit
d'un pass pour aller au restaurant on
est des établissements publics
là c'est autre chose parce qu'il
faudrait que chacun ait pu être vaccinés
sinon ce n'est pas plus d'éléments que
nous sur ces questions là on sait
toujours pas ce qu'il en est vraiment
vous dire ça mais c'est là et vous avez
raison de dire que la bonne
compréhension des mesures prises et
nécessaire à la bonne adhésion du public
et c'est vrai qu'on comprend pas
toujours sur quoi fondre le gouvernement
ces décisions il faut un parlement sur
ce pass and it r space il faut il faut
il faut un débat sur la sur la stratégie
de gestion de la crise sanitaire c'est
évidemment compliqué été invoquées je
vais mettre par terre
mais pourquoi pas pourquoi nous on est
prêt à tous les débats et à tous et à
tous les votes mais dans l'acte en
créant selon dans la compréhension des
enjeux dans l'explication dans la
transparence dans la pédagogie et dans
la constance qu'on ne finit pas
d'accélérer sur les masques sur les
tests et maintenant sur les vaccins de
la constance parce que nous sommes
effectivement dans une course de vitesse
et que la meilleure façon de s'en sortir
c'est quand même le vaccin
un dernier mot là dessus puisque le
virus circule de manière inégale sur le
territoire l'ouest de la france
notamment les plus épargnées on le
couvre feu et d'appeler ça pour votre
collègue d'ouest france
vous aussi le couvre-feu est le même
pour tout le monde est ce que il faut
alléger les mesures dans l'ouest de la
france ou pas nous avons plaidé
dès lors que c'était pertinent sur le
plan sanitaire de régionaliser les
réponses le régionaliser les réponses en
termes en effet de réglementation du
couvre-feu éventuellement de confinement
régionaux comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui
ça avait été le cas d'ailleurs il ya
quelques temps je pense à la mayenne oui
si c'est possible il faut le faire en
tant que faire se peut différencier la
réponse par la situation sanitaire des
règles des allégements avec des
allègements chaque fois que cela est
possible
évidemment et surtout pardon mais donner
de la perspective
ce dont les uns et les autres ont besoin
c'est la perspective regarde en israël
on atteint immunité collective
on va rouvrir les restaurants et un
certain nombre de lieux le premier
ministre britannique a donné de la
perspective on sait d'ici l'été quel
sera le rythme des ouvertures d'écoles
je crois que c'était hier et puis
progressivement des commerces des lieux
culturels etc etc
le gouvernement parle de mi-avril ça
vous semble envisageable
ecoutez jean sérien ils annoncent
souvent des dates et puis il dit on
croise les doigts mais on peut pas
fonder une politique sur le fait de
croiser les doigts
on va parler des droits des femmes
stéphane oui alors sur le c'était le lit
mars s'est testé hier on a un petit peu
de retard mais vrai savoir qu'est ce que
c'est ça les droits des femmes c'est pas
que lui marche c'est toute une journée
de lutte mais enfin qui doit pas
s'éclipser être éclipsée par le reste de
l'année mais on va saisir cette occasion
pour en parler est ce que vous
reconnaissez que le gouvernant a fait
des choses en matière d'égalité hommes
femmes des choses intéressantes sur le
sujet ou pas bien sûr il a fait des
choses intéressantes par exemple
bah écoutez je pense à l'index égalité
dans les entreprises c'est important
parce que vous songez par exemple que si
toutes les femmes étaient payées comme
les hommes
ça ferait plus de richesses pour le pour
le pays ça ferait plus de 2 de
croissance plus de justice évidemment
aussi
donc oui et ce qu'il en a fait
suffisamment non parce que je manque
mais d'abord il manque des moyens
il manque des moyens parce que le budget
on peut le tourner dans tous les sens en
réalité on n'arrive jamais à l'édition
que fait le gouvernement
les associations sont le premier à le
dire il ya l'augmentation du congé du
congé parental par le gouvernement il
faudra aller au delà c'est la
proposition que nous faisons avec neuf
semaines parce que nous pensons neuf
semaines obligatoires
oui parce que nous pensons que cela va
trop facile parce que nous pensons que
en réalité l'égalité elle se construit
là il ya une rupture que les ruptures
professionnelles qui est
extraordinairement discriminante et au
fond si on dit ce risque il ne pèse pas
sur une femme ou un homme est au fond
sur le couple et c'est normal et c'est
la vie et c'est tant mieux
et bien c'est plus d'égalité pour tous
le monde salarial mais aussi dans les
déroulements de carrière donc c'est
effectivement extrêmement important un
dernier mot là dessus puisque la
république en marche la majorité
présidentielle veut s'attaquer aux
quotas dans les instances dirigeantes
des entreprises a priori elle devrait
déposer une proposition doit être que
vous la soutiendrai bah écoute et que la
majorité fasse déjà pression sur le
gouvernement pour qu'il y ait une vraie
parité dans les nominations publiques
commençant par ce sur quoi nous avons
apprises ensuite oui sur les conseils
d'administration saluent on a déjà
légiféré sur ce sujet là avec des
objectifs il faut aller au delà il faut
aller il faut arriver à la parité
sa part est évidemment parfaitement
justes et de bon sens mais dans la
nomination d'eric l'adresse est dans la
même innocence des faits il faut là
aussi quand même que rien en face au
travail et vous soutiendrez ce texte il
arrive probablement on va parler de la
loi qui m'a alors les députés ont débuté
hier l'examen de la ouate climat l'issue
des travaux la convention citoyenne donc
vous avez deux semaines l'examen en
commission spéciale qui vous attendent
quel est votre proposition sur ce texte
sur sept alors soit libéré d'abord on
partage les mêmes la circonspection et
la déception de beaucoup
s'agissant de cette loi le climat vous
avez vu que les citoyens eux mêmes qui
avaient été invités à travailler pour
une transition climatique dans la
justice sociale ont donné une très
mauvaise note salée on va dire voilà ce
qui est doublement décevant est
doublement ennuyeux mais elle était
restée environnementale à gré tout pensé
vous avez aussi des sujets mieux de ne
pas noter les notaires les notices
heures vous savez comme comme on dit et
vous donner un seul exemple ça fait
partie de nos propositions
il ya dans les propositions de la
convention climat la question de la
rénovation thermique des logements c'est
un gisement d'économies d'énergie
considérable moment absolument
considérable et il plaidait pour une
rénovation complète et performante et
pour qu'on sorte des passoires
énergétiques
très vite nous avons fait une
proposition nous l'art formuleront dents
le texte de sortir des passoires
énergétiques en dix ans et 12 millions
de françaises et de français qui vivent
dans cette précarité là où le reste à
vivre et dérisoire parce que le
chauffage par exemple occupe une place
considérable
c'est un système qui est au fond assez
rodée c'est zéro reste à charge pas
d'argent à débourser au moment des
travaux et la partie qui ne serait pas
subventionner parce qu'évidemment il une
subvention sur des notes sur des
critères sociaux avec les terres de
revenus il se serait remboursé au moment
de la mutation sert de la vente ou
d'héritage des rénovations complètes et
performantes pour pas faire des à-coups
est ce qu'on en est là dans les
propositions du gouvernement
non est ce que dans les propositions qui
sont faites
nous allons atteindre la cible d'une
neutralité carbone à l'horizon 2050 non
plus tôt on aura plutôt 20 ans de retard
on peut pas se le permettre
et donc nous devons accélérer comme sur
les vaccins mais nous c'est ce que nous
proposons par exemple dans les
amendements que nous avons déposés
c'est la prime climat il ya un autre
texte qui est examinée qui concerne le
climat qui est examiné aujourd'hui par
les députés c est celui qui vise à
introduire dans la constitution à
modifier la constitution pour introduire
la garantie de la préservation de
l'environnement emmanuel macron 20 un
référendum sur ce sujet est-ce que vous
voterez le texte qui est examiné à
l'assemblée aujourd'hui
oui et je voudrais vous dire que en 2018
vous en souvenez il y avait une projet
de réforme constitutionnelle qui était
un peu contrarié par la sphère bénard
pour dire les choses puisque le
gouvernement a remisé ce projet nous
avions déposé des amendements et parmi
ceux-là nous avions fait la proposition
que soit inscrit dans la constitution et
bien la protection de l'environnement
c'est pour ça que nous soutiendrons ce
texte l'ensemble du parti et c'est ce
qu'il faudra on va écouter je moi je
suis porte parole du groupe socialiste
et du parti suisse oui on le fond on le
fera bien sûr et vous êtes confiant sur
le référendum pour qui le référendum il
faut qu'il soit voté en termes
identiques
c'est vous dire écoutez je suis
incapable de vous dire qu'elle est
qu'elle sera là vous souhaitez que ça
ils ont encore un homme oui je crois que
c'est souhaitable
enfin je veux dire c'est souhaitable
pour la question climatique et
environnementale c'est quand même ça
l'enjeu c'est pas nous c'est pas un
c'est pas ces souhaite un réseau l'est
pas est ce qu'on n'est pas dans la
symbolique est ce que ça va vraiment
être utile puisque coûté et plein de
plein de constitution avec eux c'est
déjà dans le bloc alors dû sionnel les
raisons
finalement ça sert à rien vous avez
raison de dire que la charte de
l'environnement à valeur
constitutionnelle et que évidemment
c'est symbolique mais ça tu dois dire
aussi l'ordre de nos priorités pour
l'avenir il au référendum permettrait ça
en fait d'affirmer cette série côté ça
permet de 0,6 et ça permet de dire aussi
à ceux qui nous gouvernent aujourd'hui
et à ceux j'espère sera pas les mêmes
qu'ils seront de gauche qui gouverneront
demain que au fond cela nous oblige
parce que c'est dans le texte
fondamental qui fait de la question
environnementale l'un des principes qui
font notre vie en société et la
construction et la construction d'un
lien et vous avez raison de dire que ce
n'est pas suffisant et d'ailleurs vous
voyez le gouvernement peut à la fois
proposer ce référendum et proposer une
loi climat et résilience qui n'est pas à
la hauteur des enjeux
autre sujet c'est frédéric vidal qui
était en déplacement aujourd'hui à blois
va rencontrer des étudiants et le maire
socialiste de la ville marc brigue marc
gricourt il va boycotter la venue de la
ministre en raison entre autres de
l'enquète qu'elle a lancée sur l'islamo
gauchisme dans les universités ce que
vous soutenez cette décision du maire
est ce que c'est une attitude
républicaine
écoutez ce qui est pas très républicain
c'est de pas défendre la liberté
académique ne pas défendre la liberté de
conscience et d'entretenir des
polémiques qui n'ont pas lieu d'être
lancé dans lumière l'islamo gauchisme
sait pas défendre la liberté académique
pour vous non la liberté académique
c'est le débat entre les universitaires
c'est le débat intellectuel c'est la
contradiction c'est le fait d'être
d'accord de ne pas être d'accord il ya
beaucoup de controverses ya toujours eu
beaucoup de controverse dans le monde
universitaire depuis toujours et c'est
tant mieux
il faut que les uns et les autres
puissent s'exprimer avec force et que la
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur
ministre de la recherche soit garant de
cette de cette liberté là il faut pas
qu'ils d'instrumentalisation on a droit
de ne pas être d'accord et la ministre a
le droit de ne pas être d'accord avec
certains travaux académiques comme moi
même je ne suis pas d'accord
certains des travaux qui peut être fait
sous tel ou tel domaine ou telle ou
telle manière matière pardon eh bien je
crois que ça quel doit être le garant et
le maire de de bois lui dit vous savez
il ya tellement les rencontres
l'histoire de blu ray bien que c'est un
bien précieux qu'il faut chérir
voilà et donc on attend ça mais vous
auriez fait la même chose
boycotter la visite de la ministre je
suis solidaire de ce que a décidé le
maire de blois parce que il dit quelque
chose à travers à travers cela il y
quelque chose et je crois que ce que
nous devons dire au delà du symbole
c'est notre attachement à l'université
dans le même temps on assista on voit
qu'à grenoble faisait deux professeurs
qui sont accusés d'être islamophobe et
qui sont jetés à la vindicte populaire
pas je le dirai jamais anonyme je le dis
avec la même force
c'est inacceptable c'est inacceptable ce
sont des méthodes qui relèvent qui ne
relève pas d'un état de droit qui ne
relève pas d'une démocratie et qui vient
aussi contredire la liberté académique
et je souhaite que ces deux professeurs
puissent de façon sereine reprendre leur
cours avec la liberté qui est la leur et
avec la possibilité des uns et des
autres de ne pas être d'accord avec ce
qui je sais pas précisément ce qu'ils
lisent mais oui les principes sont pas
divisible quand je dis liberté
académique et bien ça vaut dans tous les
méthodes inacceptables est ce que ce ne
sont pas des méthodes qui sont
directement importée des états unis une
espèce de name and shame alors à l'anglo
saxonne ou en fait on fait le procès des
gens et bien et bien vous avez raison
assange et son patron ne sais pas d'où
ça vient mais ça n'est pas ma culture
politique mais est ce que c'est une
honte à ce dîner loupé en france ob oui
y compris d'ailleurs dans les
propositions faites par le gouvernement
on parle et autres marques ont parlé
tout à l'heure d'un certain nombre de
d'entreprise dénoncé sur la place
publique comme ne respectant par bon ben
voilà est-ce que c est ce que c'est une
culture moi je suis plutôt pour que nous
ayons des règles et qu'elle s'applique
voilà et donc la contradiction c'est
important que celui j'ai eu un peu quand
j'étais à l'université j'ai eu un
professeur qui était à l'époque au front
national figure éminente du front
national qu'elle avait même été député
européen est bien dans le désaccord que
j'ai avec lui je n'ai jamais mis après
le premier cours les pieds c'est qui a
son siège
c'était monsieur martinez on va parler
politique pour terminer mon plus grand
regret est de ne pas avoir pu me
représenter c'est ce qu'a dit françois
hollande hier ils étaient sûrs twitch
que pensez vous de cette phrase moi je
le conçois quand on est pris on a un
public on a toujours évidemment le
l'espérance de pouvoir se représenter de
pouvoir être aussi nous savons sur
volonté m réélu après je crois que il ne
faut pas vivre de regrets et je suis
certain que françois ne vit pas de
regrets il a du mal à tourner la page
françois hollande est ce qu'il a un
frein maintenant pour la reconstruction
du parti socialiste je ne crois pas il
s'exprime quand il pense qu'il le doit
s'exprimer
non je dis pas ça il a été président de
la république ce qu'il a dit sur le
parquet national financier et sur
l'indépendance de la justice ce week-end
c'était salutaire j'aurais aimé
l'entendre dans la bouche du président
de la république en fonction qui est le
garant de l'indépendance de la justice
il se représentera pas dit non j'ai
écouté j'ai pas de compétences
particulières parce que je les aurais
fait j'en sais rien mais je ne crois pas
que se fasse du tout ni son projet ni
son attention aux traces et celle de
julien bayou steyer soir sur notre
antenne emmanuel macron se voulait un
rempart contre le rassemblement national
il est devenu un carburant du populisme
est ce que vous partagez cette phrase
coûté manifestement et se sont ils se
sont choisis à la méjane le pen oui
chacun finit par faire subrepticement la
campagne de l'autre c'est très
préoccupant
c'est très préoccupant de 130 j'aimerais
que oui on est le le le le même débat
qu'il offre à l'extrême droite avec avec
cette majorité que l'on puisse montrer
qu'il ya des alternatives entre le
libéralisme et le nationalisme et je le
crois à dire c'est notre responsabilité
que de construire cette alternative avec
un chemin qui est celui de la justice de
l'égalité et du programme pas la
question du front républicain se pose de
plus en plus vous en cas de duel
hypothétique entre emmanuel macron et
marine le pen qu'est-ce que vous mais
moi je ferai toujours remparts à
l'extrême droite donc vous feriez
clergerie mais je ne crois mais vous
savez pourquoi je me bats pas pour faire
la démonstration que je voterai contre
marine le pen
mais pour faire la démonstration que ça
n'est pas un tête à tête irrémédiable et
que franchement le pays mérite mieux que
cela comprenait ses électeurs de gauche
mais je l'entends et vous allécher
je lire libération pour pour eux pour
l'entendre je l'entends depuis des mois
parce qu'il ya une grande trahison du
président de la république vis-à-vis de
ceux qui l'ont porté à la présidence de
la république parce qu'il a été élu et
il a oublié dans des circonstances très
particulières il n'a pas été élu au
premier tour
comme ils ne pensent comme la majorité
le pense il a été au second tour par les
français et les françaises républicain
dans la diversité second par les 13
sièges à ce que dit gabriela talent qui
vient du parti social et je vais aussi
il dit les engagements qui ont fait
vibrer les électeurs de gauche en 2017
ont été tenues depuis un an la gestion
de la crise sanitaire est pur mensonge
vous savez on peut sauter sur sa chaise
en disant on a tout fait on a tout fait
bon la réalité est tout autre
et moi je comprends il est porte parole
du gouvernement écrit son boulot mais
enfin j'entends aussi y compris dans ses
rangs beaucoup de gens déçus et beaucoup
sont partis parce que précisément ils
considéraient qu'il avait été dupé
alors le problème c'est qu'on a presque
un an de la présidentielle et pour
l'instant à gauche c'est toujours
personne personne qui émergent les
sondages
aucune figure majeure le lait chaud sont
pas si sûr il n'y a pas de violence
d'abord qu'est-ce que concours il vole
une figure majeure qui sont des
candidats bhl mais là la vraie
contre la montre et le tournage jours de
l'échéance vous avez entendu là - mais
sinon il pas dire qu'il y ait de
déclarations de candidatures à gauche la
droite et même dans la majorité est ce
que le président se se représentera ou
pas je n'en sais rien et vous avez vu
les derniers sondages qui a été publié
en début de semaine dans l'hôtel à
égalité avec nicolas dupont aignan ya ça
vous un gars il faut du pognon il est
candidat permanent
non ça ne m'inquiète pas parce que je
pense que les choses vont se décanter
qui est un travail de fond qui est fait
on a présenté la semaine dernière et le
mois précédent certains chapitres de
notre projet sur notre rapport au
travail
notre rapport à la santé avec des
propositions extrêmement concrètes en
prenant appui sur cette crise dont les
leçons nous nous oblige et bien sûr
qu'il faut qu'il faut s'unir et proposer
une alternative parce que j'ai pu
trouver quelqu'un pour incarner tout ça
et on le trouvera n'ayez pas de doute et
non des gens de qualité dans les mois
qui ne pouvez pas ne soyez pas
impatients comme ça votre impatience
au fond c'est une compris c'est l
espérance que ça a donné une réponse
merci vous
merci d'avoir été notre invité à
regarder une de ouest france stéphane on
en parlait égalité en entreprise les
quotas sont ils un mal nécessaire
c'est la question que vous posez dans
votre que vous posez dans votre journal
merci beaucoup on passe vite au club de
taille tant la mutuelle nationale
territoriale
la mutuelle des agents des services
publics locaux je vous présente le club
[Musique]